this is the IBM personal computer it was
the most advanced computing machine ever
created however this isn't a story about
a computer but a story about when a
computer stops working and the man who
created a way to start it all over the
man who invented control-alt-delete
let's get into it
[Music]
hi I'm dr. Dave Bradley but you can call
me dr. Dave back in 1980 I worked on the
IBM personal computer my particular job
on the IBM PC was writing the basic
input/output system even with an elite
team of engineers and designers not
everything goes smoothly when you're
building a computer we had programs that
ran most of the time but when they
failed the only way to reset the system
was turn the power off wait awhile turn
the power back on and it would go
through a very long self-test but the
system might die every 5 to 10 minutes
what he needed was a way to shortcut the
restart process one of the things we
discussed was putting a reset button on
it but if you put it on the system board
there was a chance that you could hit it
by mistake and all your data gets lost
so what we did was came up with a three
key sequence who would reset to this
computer and you couldn't hit by mistake
a single control key a single Alt key
and then all the way over at the right
hand side a single Delete key
when you hit that control-alt-delete
you're deleting everything that you're
working on right now and starting new I
was also able to skip over many of the
tests so instead of taking a minute or
two it was ten or fifteen seconds but it
wasn't a big deal at the time it was
like number 17 on the list of a hundred
different things I had to fix even
though it was built only as a
development tool programmers began
incorporating the feature into their
applications from there it was released
into the wild but didn't immediately
reach pop culture status for years there
was no big deal and then at the 20th
anniversary of the IBM PC that's when
control off the leaf became sort of a
cultural icon it was the simplest and
easiest way to fit your problem hit
control-alt-delete start all over
despite all this dr. Dave doesn't think
much of this contribution to computing
history I get lots of things with IBM
but all everybody remembers this
control-alt-delete but I'll take that
the fame of control-alt-delete means
that I worked on a very successful
product and I'm very proud of having
been able to do that
[Music]
you